ever since apple announced the switch to
their own custom apple silicon chips for
the mac lineup
intel has been under a ton of pressure
from their investors
to step up their game especially after
apple released
the m1 max which have been blowing
everyone away
so just yesterday intel announced their
weapon to fight back
and hold on to their market share and
that is of course
alder lake which is their next
generation of chips
that are actually hybrids meaning that
they'll have both big cores
and little cores which is what apple has
been doing
for years with all of their chips and
it's actually what's helped the new m1
mac
get industry leading performance and
battery life at the same time
now intel was already using this hybrid
tech with their lakefield chips
but those were heavily focused on
battery life
only having one big core with four
efficiency cores
alder lake is going to be a totally
different beast so in this video
i'm gonna explain exactly how alder lake
will work
when we can expect it to get released
how it'll compete
with apple's chips and i'm even gonna
look at some leaked alder lake
benchmarks
to see if intel can finally make a
comeback now the very first thing i want
to mention is that
when apple completes their transition to
their own ships
they will never again use intel ever
that ship has sailed and within the next
few months
apple is gonna release some new m1x
powered max and the performance is gonna
be mind-blowing
so keep in mind that intel's alder lake
will be competing
with at least the m1x not the current
and one chip
intel says that alder lake will be here
in the second half of 2021
but based on their past there's a good
chance that it's gonna get delayed just
checking out the macromers forums
there are multiple users who doubt that
intel will have them ready this year
with one user claiming that rumors are
already pointing to a 2022 release date
but enough with all of that let's dig
into how alder lake actually works
first off the most interesting detail is
that it'll use the 10
nanometer architecture not the seven
nanometer
like many people were hoping for so
that's a bit disappointing
since amd has already been making seven
nanometer chips
for an entire year already now if you're
wondering how the whole big
little chip design will work there
apparently was a leak
showing 12 different possible
configurations to the s
series of alder lake chips with the
highest one having eight big cores
eight little cores and one gpu core and
interestingly there were also some
configurations
with no little cores at all so i suspect
that those are
actually for desktop systems that don't
rely on battery power
like laptops do so they don't need any
little cores
which are meant to be efficient so the
models with the little cores are only
meant
for the laptop and mobile segment so
they can save
battery life which is one of the most
important factors in
a great laptop and that's exactly what
we saw with apple's m1
macbook pro with up to 20 hours of
battery life
which is incredible in fact apple just
published a support
article showing the difference in power
consumption and
thermal output between the m1 mac mini
and the high-end intel mac mini the
intel model basically consumes
three times more power while at idle and
while maxed out and it puts out less
than three times the amount of heat
with only a maximum of 133 btus per hour
that means a max server farm can get
three
m1 powered mac minis for the same power
and thermal price
of one intel mac mini which means that
they can save a significant amount of
money
on electricity and their cooling system
but wait
it gets even crazier the m1 mac mini is
actually eight percent faster
than the highest end intel mac mini in
terms of the cinebench r23 stress test
and then if you look at graphics
performance it's over four
times faster so this is a no-brainer
for servers showing that intel is in a
lot of trouble
in the server space as well especially
when apple releases
the m1x mac mini and this whole
efficiency difference is extremely
important for laptops
and that's why apple's macbooks can run
at full performance
while on just battery power alone while
many windows laptops
slow down drastically in order to save
battery life now
alder lake is meant to fix that problem
so let's see what intel has up their
sleeves in terms of performance
the best chip will feature 16 cores
eight big
and eight small and it looks like we
already have some leaked benchmarks from
an early engineering sample
this new chip scored 996 points in terms
of single core
and 69 31 points in multi-core which
obviously isn't great for a 16 core chip
but it seems like all of the cores were
only running at 1.38 gigahertz
for this engineering sample at least the
big core the big cores
the big cores will likely run much
faster potentially over 4.8 gigahertz
so we can expect a multi-core score of
well over 10
000 which is actually really impressive
but keep in mind
that this is the top of the line alder
lake chip but what makes it very
interesting
is that a data has been confirmed to be
the manufacturer of the ram models
4 alder lake chips with up to 64 gigs of
ram per stick
and up to a massive 8 400 megahertz
speed
which is absolutely insane
videocards.com leaked a photo of the
very first alder lake s cpu
which has a new rectangular shape using
the brand new
lga 1700 socket so it shows that apple
needs a larger socket
to fit all of that in it getting even
deeper
intel's long-term vision is to stick the
memory into the chip
package itself which is exactly what
apple
is currently doing with their custom
chips like the m1
using the unified architecture this
could help make alder lake very
competitive
especially if it supports pci express
5.0
which has been rumored for some time
this all seems to make a lot of sense
for intel
and they're even looking to scale these
hybrid chips
across their entire lineup in the future
so they seem to be going
all in on this new technology however
there's a massive hurdle that intel is
gonna have to get over
one that apple has already solved and
that's
software support while the concept of
having both big and little cores
sounds great the software has to be able
to properly utilize the cores
to make them all fire up during high
performance tasks
or for simple tasks only having the
efficiency course running
windows will have to know how to
properly handle this
as well as the app that you're running
amd actually came out and said that this
big little core design doesn't really
make sense
until software catches up because
everything from the scheduler
the memory allocator and the memory
subsystem
need to be in tune with the software so
there's a chance that intel could be
jumping the gun a little bit
unless they're secretly in talks with
windows to get
software support up and ready but in my
opinion
i think this is intel's only chance to
get back into the game
and they did mention that they'll be
implementing a next-gen
hardware scheduler alongside alder lake
so that should definitely help
with the transition now on the other
hand apple has been working with
big little arm technology for years
already
in fact the a10 fusion chip from the
iphone 7
was the first apple chip to use this
technology
and that was almost five years ago so
they have a ton of experience with it
not only that but apple has a very
unique advantage that almost nobody out
there has
they control the software the hardware
and the chip itself all at the same time
and that's why m1 max works so well if
you remember a couple of years ago when
apple dropped 32-bit app support on the
mac
or when they dropped nvidia graphics
because they refused to support apple's
metal api
all of those changes were actually part
of apple
transitioning their software years in
advance
to get ready for the m1 max
and obviously intel doesn't have that
advantage
because the only thing they control is
the chip on top of that
apple has been buying out all or most of
the yields for the best chips in the
business
from tsmc so with all of that together
it's going to be extremely hard for
intel to catch up and if you look even
further into the future
if arm chips end up outperforming x86
chips on every level
intel will be even more behind since
these new alder lake chips
are still using x86 both samsung
and qualcomm have already been making
arm-based chips for years
so i suspect many windows laptop makers
will simply go with them
instead if they want to maximize battery
life and performance
and even amd is much closer than intel
since they already create
arm-based chips like the opteron a 1100
for servers
and according to recent leaks and rumors
amd is already working on an
arm-based soc similar to apple's m1 chip
there was even amd's project sky bridge
from a few years back which intended to
pack both
x86 cores and arm cores on the same
chip being the perfect hybrid
transitionary chip
so i wonder if amd's gonna work on that
but either way
based on everything that i discussed in
this video there are a lot of hurdles
that intel is going to have to pass
through
and if they end up delaying alder lake
into 2022
they could end up way too far behind so
there you guys go
let me know what you guys think about
alder lake and the whole intel versus
apple thing
down in the comments below be sure to
check out one of those two videos right
there
click the circle above to subscribe and
we'll see you in the next video